what's up everybody my name is O Hara
and today I'm gonna share with you guys
three reasons why IQ is amazing have you
ever watched a show that some how could
you downright hooked on something you
had no interest in at all or even
genuinely disliked well you probably
know where this story is going but I'm
gonna tell it anyway
because that is exactly what happened to
me when I first discovered high q-- I
mean not only did I not care for
volleyball but the bunch of times I was
forced to play during high school I
found the game painfully underwhelming
usually going home with a bunch of
burning phrases on all my knees and
elbows and then through a couple of
nerdy years and one season of high Q
later I'm standing in a gym excited out
of my mind to play some volleyball how
the hell did that happen now I'm
guessing that this story at least to
some degree might sound very familiar to
you and I think we all can agree that
whenever among our anime manages to
spark such a sudden passion for
something that we used to have no
interest in before whatsoever it must be
doing something very very right so if
you like me and you're wondering how the
heck and anime about volleyball above
all things became so widely popular and
unbearably entertaining you came to the
right place because in this video we'll
be discussing the three things that make
high Q one of the top Shonen of the new
era I would say compared to your average
Shonen anime high q-- does most things
pretty well that a decent Shonen needs
like having an appealing art style or
having adequate pacing with all of these
things how to eat seafood ADATA the
author of high q-- does a pretty damn
good job overall however what really
sets the story apart from the average
Shonen anime are three things in which
high q-- easily surpasses much of its
competition which also allowed it to
successfully run and show ninja magazine
for over eight years these three things
are the spot-on use of a completely
polarizing protagonist duo it's
perfectly crafted story structure and
finally the immense
of realism and research that how to eat
she has put into his work to make the
story feel as incredibly convincing and
intriguing as it is so let's start by
taking a closer look at the two heroes
of our story first of all before we get
into the two protagonists I want to
mention that I believe IQ has a very
strong character set up in general over
the course of the story we increasingly
meet new teams with new characters and
philosophies and somehow most if not all
of them are immensely well-developed and
easy to connect with that being said
let's move on to our heroes the main
characters in high Q are the small but
hard-working Hinata show yo as well as
the talented but socially awkward
Kageyama Toby o strictly speaking the
story focuses more on Hinata as he
follows the road of the typical Shonen
hero
however Kageyama comes very close and
importance and enjoys a similar amount
of screen time what makes this quite
unlikely duo such a fantastic premise
for the story however is exactly that
they are the exact opposite of each
other Hinata is incredibly charismatic
and easily forms relationships with
teammates and opponents alike his
biggest weakness are his lack in height
as well as his inexperience that he has
to overcome through hard work and
training
Kageyama on the other hand has been
blessed with immense talent and instinct
for the sport and is one of the most
promising young prodigies in the country
however he likes basic social skills
that isolate him from his teammates as a
result he not an Kageyama have
completely opposing character arts where
one has to become better and stronger on
the court while the other has to become
a better person and learn how to form
real friendships two very popular themes
of Shonen that how to eg splits into two
characters here
what both have in common however is
their strong will to fight and work hard
in order to grow so in essence high Q is
about these two ambitious young men with
opposing strengths and weaknesses that
strives to become the best volleyball
players in the country by learning
from each other and growing together one
striving to become stronger and want to
become a better person the lesson here
is that one can be successful without
the other
and this makes both of them immensely
easy to identify with and makes us once
you see both of them succeed now the
next thing we have to talk about is high
Q's crazily perfected story structure
one of the most important criteria for a
great Shonen story at least according to
hirohiko Araki the author of JoJo's is
that the protagonists are always rising
rising and yeah you guessed it rising
again but the reason why an always
rising arc is so important is that we
always want to see the character keep
progressing further even if he has a
setbacks and low points the overall
development always points upwards
towards being a bit better than the last
chapter to better visualize this point
imagine a manga where the hero is weak
and friendless at the beginning nothing
too uncommon right however if he never
gets any better no matter how hard he
tries it would be kind of depressing to
keep watching this person's eternal
struggle right no what we want to see in
Shonen is how our heroes succeed and
grow and finally manage to be that one
annoyingly arrogant guy there always is
an annoyingly arrogant guy as you might
have guessed s' high Q has brought this
always rising structure to absolute
perfection the story starts with Hinata
being the only person on his volleyball
team during middle school not even
having the chance to have proper
practice but having to force his friends
to toss in balls from there the story
progresses from finally joining karasuno
high the former school of his idol /
playing at the inter high than the
spring high all the way to the Tokyo
Nationals despite having to face
progressively harder challenges along
the way
our heroes prevail in the end and keep
fighting and growing this gives the
entire series a sense of continuous
positive motion that we all want to be a
part of
the reason that not more anime can pull
off the tactic of the always rising arc
by using tournaments is what do you do
once the tournament is over and how do
you come up with increasingly stronger
and stronger opponents for the heroes
without becoming too repetitive haikyuu
solves these two quite common problems
by ending the series once a true high
point has been reached and more
importantly maybe is that Haru Ichi lets
his antagonists grow as well and have
them be a natural part of the journey
rival teams like nekoma or Alba juice I
grow alongside the car Asano team and
additionally we might have opponents
that might not be as strong as core
Asano
but have unique tactics or a unique
setup with which they can pose a true
threat to Hinata and Kageyama everything
in the story's development feels organic
and that already brings me to my final
points setting so what's so super
exciting about the setting in hai cube I
mean it's pretty much our normal world
right we have Japanese high schools with
teams that play volleyball in
tournaments no crazy magical powers no
furries no nothing well let me tell you
that it's actually exactly the
seamlessness of the Heike world that
makes it so good to watch the level of
realism and naturalness that how Ichi
creates is what fully emerges the reader
so us into the story and that's what
sparks this level of passion for the
sport he has without any doubt sunk
hours over hours into research about his
story from the basic rules and
techniques of the game over the
structures of Japanese high school
volleyball all the way to the history
and organization of the club's
themselves this includes pretty mundane
stuff you probably never thought about
like how many referees are there at each
tournaments or how do the uniforms have
to look or how does the sports club
actually finance itself all these things
are just there and make it easy for you
to lose yourself in the story but if
these things hadn't been thought about
properly the plot would surely have been
very different
can you imagine watching a sports anime
where the techniques aren't correct
you'll always know something is kind of
off and especially so if you actually
like the sport itself so I guess my
point here is for amazing anime the
devil truly lies in the detail and
haikyuu does a damn good job at it
so good even that professional player
Kim Jung kun praised the accuracy of the
anime in a review on her personal
YouTube channel noting that the creator
of the series must be a person with high
level of volleyball knowledge so if a
pro is able to enjoy the show to its
fullest it's no real surprise that we
can as well
so to recap what makes high q-- standout
among so many others shown in anime
today it has an incredibly intriguing
and fun protagonists duo it has a
constantly rising story structure in
which we see Hinata
Kageyama and really almost everyone else
in the show work incredibly hard to
become better players and better people
which let's face it is just ridiculously
entertaining to watch and finally the
story world is researched and created in
so much detail and with so much
dedication that it's really hard not to
become involved in it these three extra
ordinarily well-executed things are what
make haikyuu a true top Shonen of the
new era and goddamn now I really want to
go out and play but you know you can't
so that's it for today guys let me know
what you think about haikyuu and what
other shows I should talk about on this
channel if you enjoyed this video leave
me a thumbs up and if you want to hear
more of me over analyzing anime manga
make sure to hit that subscribe button
with the little bell I hope to see you
around next time and until then have a
wonderful week